how's Gomes my spirit hi today we're
gonna play on the a pain rapper career
incoming I can rhyme two words
so my girlfriend suggested this game she
had been playing it she's like you have
to play this hello row and as such
pretty pretty pretty music and ads get
off me cow
wow it's so soothing and wonderful I
love it
let's play it alright time
oh wow her best is for what okay I can
tap back and forth oh I got it I got it
I got it [ __ ] seriously are you for
reals this brick is not amazing this
prank is a piece of [ __ ]
I'd [ __ ] bigger bricks on you bigger boy
oh oh oh oh I got three oh I'm coming
for you mines yeah
not in that way though god dammit
someone's gonna sample that Oh what I'm
never gonna be oh no oh oh oh god [ __ ] I
was amazing
look at this look at this look at it
just like Oh God
okay if you do one mistake you can't
recover in this game this game is not
about recovering
it's about murdering bricks seriously
this calming music is just to [ __ ] with
your mind isn't it it's like you made
you mad no you mad no seriously bro you
know but I agree [ __ ] you
yes I am what do you want oh come on
just hurts me get zero this reminds me
of where you are in life oh oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh [ __ ] you can't recover if
you take yes this is how we hardly Oh
moving with you [ __ ] me I gotta be eight
I'm not going home until I be eight I am
home so guy by DM a problem by well
figuring out together process that's
what life is I I stop distracting me
okay I oh oh oh oh who the hell now bro
hey alright we can you recently oh oh oh
no boy no [ __ ] day no
that is Spanish right let his racist
boots it's not racist unless you like it
I'm sorry Spanish people Yo no hablo
espanol and tu madres me partly that
means I love you right someone taught me
that I don't remember who we this piano
music in American it's like I'm playing
Sims but the graphics are actually
better I'm just kidding I'm just kidding
I love Sims I love my Anna Collin that
[ __ ] I still haven't bad wait I got a
night this one a good night I don't
never realize this is like the new
Freiberg right except it's not a bird
and it's not flapping but otherwise if
you're fighting break [ __ ] this is
pretty damn addicting to [ __ ] hey guy
don't sign you didn't do anything I just
felt like blaming him alright come on
you gotta get 10/10 we can do [ __ ] me no
we can never do it we can never be wit
but that's what life is you gotta keep
trying
I like unless you start trying how can
you not fail anymore I should be the
slogan of this game I'm really trying
here I feel like I should be really good
at these type of games considering how
much I play them right nope so suck Oh
God maybe it's my there we go 9
nicely it gets actually not even in the
room I just feel like yelling at him the
spirit of Edgar is still here so so [ __ ]
me Deutschland little alert Oh Edgar you
are here Jesus you scared my tits off I
don't have tits to begin win so that
might help you think you know someone
and then there just a break that was
[ __ ]
right left right I'm on fire I'm on fire
what yeah that's amazing
stammers amaz me oh I get it now I get
it
that's why it's called amazing brakes
because it's it's so [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
that's what a day I'm just kidding
here we go come on come on come on come
on you really just gotta get that flow
ho you know you just oh oh oh oh oh I'm
sorry did you want me to take you out on
a date Hey oh man this game is fun man I
don't even know me Adam Adam oh man are
you man I'm a woman
your man warming oh I'm sorry I don't
mean to thank you I didn't I don't know
[ __ ]
well tell me more about this man woman
nice you have really soft cheeks are you
sure okay I'll stop I'll stop talking
about your cheeks I'm sorry
okay can you cheer me on or something I
don't know sing a song or some shade I'm
listening come on
just sing about how good I am okay
you're happy okay that's pretty I make
it say hey you know what a 10-second
have a lovely voice have you ever
considered being an American Idol very
start you're scared of that Simon guy
well it guess what he's scared of you to
my going show and what you're worth
that's my today's inspirational speech
that's all you're getting from me for
today [ __ ] I need inspiration
god dammit I'm too generous God yeah you
place it there literally literally I
send really and literally at the same
time in every type of movie all right
wow I can really get through one now
good job I like was getting stuck like
it has a good flow in the hole if you
know what I'm so see that [ __ ] that's
what in Sweden we call some real OG [ __ ]
one final attempt to be my high score
then that'll be it
Abbi yeah uh-huh that's how we oh my god
ah yeah I hate you all right come on
come on now seriously trihard whoa ah
[ __ ] you do skills and then you become a
hill I hate when that happens
hate it I want to be my [ __ ] high
score I am not addicted I am NOT a dick
dad mom mom don't take my xbox one of my
friends gonna say damn it I want to be
my [ __ ] high school [ __ ] you
just [ __ ] game is ruining me I'm
gonna be here all night
sorry bro this is not gonna be any
videos for like a couple weeks I just
grilling me be despised god damn it I
gotta weep sir hey [ __ ] oh god [ __ ] you
jumped so high what are you gettin high
no I do not have a problem I could stop
playing whenever I want
three hours later get off the car Oh God
okay oh oh oh that recovery bro oh [ __ ]
or you sandwich me up here up me car
enough me come 109 bitte Schon
[ __ ]
ah alright hope you enjoy the Cyprus no
I'm gonna [ __ ] be done again I don't
have a problem please meet nice good
please for this [ __ ] okay why did I
get in lovin I can't Jack Garratt like
him like in a bike and this sweater bike
hope you enjoyed this episode I'll leave
a link to check out the game yourself
and I'll see you the next one
thanks for saying thanks for watching
and I'll see you
breathy